my name is teres maposa
also known as the prince machiavelli i'm
29 years old
and i'm a farmer in zimbabwe the journey
to
becoming a farmer it came after a
realization that
i need a lasting solution to my personal
financial problems
[Applause]
it's difficult it's almost impossible to
get employment after college
or after attending even all-level
certificate on a level certificate
but this land issue has been
and it's still going to create
employment especially nowadays
right now i'm in a small village you can
see it's a small small village
i don't own land here this small space
is for my mom
so if my mom tomorrow decides to chase
me away that means i'm landless
believe the land reform program now
should be targeted
at the youth because we are the future
and the future is now so for us to
secure the future of other generations
to come we need to give the youth
the land maybe the government would need
to take um
land audit maybe and see those who are
utilizing it positively and those who
are not
and those who are not they should be
taken off them and be given to the
youths who are showing
signs of potential to utilize the land
positively
to be honest i see
a sharp growth in my business
considering where
where and how i started and where i am
right now uh
i'm managing to take care of my family
take care of myself
and even to expand more so for me
something positive and i'm liking it
and i believe in decades to come
zimbabwe will be at its
original position as the bright basket
of of africa or southern africa
i believe so because the youths are now
taking a stand